[Music]
welcome to session number 56 in the
worlds of speculative fiction series so
this is a now online entirely series
that began in 2016 originally as a
face-to-face recorded series focusing on
all sorts of authors and their narrative
worlds in speculative fiction so
everything from
fantasy through sci-fi with detours and
horror and new weird and alternate
history and even some nonsense stuff as
well along the way
just so long as it was speculative
fiction just so long as there was a
narrative world that could be explored
with some coherent themes and we started
out originally as i just mentioned in
face-to-face meetings at the brookfield
public library due to covid we went
completely online after a hiatus of
several months and that is what we've
been doing now i talk for roughly 90
minutes about the author their biography
the works some of the key philosophical
themes or ideas
and we never by the way get through
enough of that and then after that we
have a live session through video
conferencing for people who want to dig
in deeper we do this generally every
month unless i get too busy and this
month is a really special treat
officially we're looking at this book
with a
cover that
the author would be rolling in his grave
over as we'll talk about in a moment
solaris
by the great uh speculative fiction
author sci-fi author self-identify
stanislaw lem
from poland one of the you know great
writers east of the the iron curtain
and who made some really significant
contributions not just
through writing science fiction but
through his
commentary about it and also
other
ways as well you can call him a futurist
he turns out to have been a futurist who
made some pretty good predictions as
opposed to some of the others and we'll
get into that in just a moment now the
reason why we picked stannis law lem
for this time is because the polish
government actually has declared this
the year of stanislaus
and there's a very important anniversary
this month of september 2021 as well
so i thought you know people have been
asking me
to do lem for a very long time
we should definitely get him in in here
and we planned for that to be the case
uh at the beginning of 2021 so here we
finally
are looking at lem and i'm actually
going to give you a little bit of
backstory before we jump into the
presentation per se
um i i wanted it to be about some sort
of coherent set of stories
so originally
i was looking at the
set of stories that are centered around
this space man character who's kind of a
kind of a screw-up in some ways uh
ijantiki and there's there's quite a few
books out there
in which he features centrally but what
i discovered
is unfortunately in this area there's
not an awful lot of lem in the libraries
with the exception of a few
novels like solaris so
the short stories that were in these
like in you know the futurological
congress
um
any of those things i've been reading
them and listening to them over this
last year i think they're they're
brilliant they're funny they're they
show a lot of insight into lem's ideas
but they just weren't going to be as
easily
found for for my audience and i knew
that there's there's like millions of
copies of solaris floating around it's
probably his most famous novel because
it's been adapted to film three times
in ways that lem himself
at least the the russian adaptations
wasn't into we'll talk about that in
just a bit and um so i thought well
let's let's focus on solaris but let's
also look at some of the other novels in
which
similar themes are coming up so if
you've got a copy of solaris you're
golden
but i also want to talk about two other
novels in particular one of which is a
little bit before solaris called eden
also dealing with the
question of making contact with alien
races or civilizations
uh in this case on the planet that they
they name eden and then a later book
called his master's voice about a
project here
on you know terra earth
trying to decipher an alien transmission
that they managed to to capture and the
failure to to do so there are some
really important common themes involved
in all of these works
i also am going to be bringing in a few
of lem's own
non-fiction let's call them
declarations and conjectures so
one of them is his
pretty interesting book summa technology
right
joking off of thomas aquinas's so
mateologia right we now live in a
technological
not just era but
you could say
we have a technological existence and
there are some discussions in this great
work of futurology
that have to do with the possibility of
making contact with alien races so we're
going to look at some of the sections of
that and then you know lem was as i
mentioned not just a writer but also a
critic and i think that his criticism
helps us to understand his own
point of view as an author so there's
this great
collection called micro worlds and in it
not only do we have some discussions
about science fiction itself which which
are
kind of pessimistic kind of kind of dark
and biting we also have reflections on
my life so when we go into the biography
period i think that will be quite
interesting to to tap but he's got so
i'm going to read you some of the titles
um science fiction a hopeless case with
exceptions one of the exceptions turns
out to be philip k dick who we'll talk
about shortly he's got another um
another piece called philip k dick a
visionary among the charlatans
which tells you what he thought of
american science fiction uh at that time
there's a lot of other cool things in
here but the other one that i want to
hit on is unitas oppositorium the pros
of jorge louis borges another author who
lam thought was quite good so i think by
looking at why he thinks are good and
why others are writing in his view crap
we can actually learn a lot about lem
himself the other thing that i thought
could be interesting to do and this is
coming from the stanislaus website
there are these compilations of
interviews carried out with lem very
helpful to have them all in one place
some of which are talking about solaris
some of which are talking about
adaptations of that whether he's a
postmodern writer
a
you know a philosopher
why he why he's not been publishing
novels at the time that they're
interviewing him just all sorts of
really
interesting and germane
topics that we want to look at so
what we're going to do in this one since
we haven't
discussed lem before
is talk a bit about his biography which
turns out to be
quite interesting in many respects
how that fits in with his literary work
um
one sort of thing to look forward to
lem
doesn't want to be a political writer
but he's writing in political times so
he
winds up having to deal with with some
political
let's call them implications and
repercussions of his work
then we'll talk about some of his own
criticism
and what that reveals about his views on
science fiction its value
its progress its potentialities its
future
and then we'll jump into talking about
these three novels giving primacy of
place of course to
solaris
and we'll talk about several key
philosophical themes that are featuring
heavily in solaris also winding up in
some of the other novels as well and
hopefully we
will get this under about 90 minutes or
so so bear with me there's there's so
much to say about this guy
stanislaw
that it's it's hard to pack in there we
might have to return to him
in a
later session in one of the years to
come
with authors that i haven't covered in
the worlds of speculative fiction series
my custom in the past has been to do a
pretty detailed biography and spend a
good bit of time on that combining the
events of their life
with the
works of the author and talking about
that but i think i'm actually going to
do something a little bit
more
quick and scenic we could say if we're
thinking about roads
in order to get to the philosophical
themes because i do want to have enough
time
you know our interest in lem i mean he
had a very interesting life but our
interest in them is in in large part
motivated by
the works that he
produces so what do we know about him
we actually learned quite a bit
again from this essay reflections on my
life which which starts before
his life begins
i'm talking about the chance playing a
role in his life and his father samuel
lamb being taken prisoner by the
russians returning to
lemberg or love
which changed hands a number of times
his native city only after five years in
the in the wake of the chaos of the
russian
revolution so you know he's fighting in
world war one gets taken prisoner
russian revolution happens a lot of
people don't really know about this but
the russian revolution destabilized not
just russia
but you could say a significant portion
of central and eastern europe as well
you know throwing things into a good bit
of chaos
and so
lem is born in 1921
and he he grows up you know in
essentially a well-to-do family
um
he's of jewish ancestry that's going to
prove important as some of his family
dies in the holocaust is raised roman
catholic but you know it doesn't really
stick and he tells us in his his uh
little essay i was a good student
some years after the war i learned from
an older man who held some position
that when it came when all the iqs of
the high school students were tested it
must have been around 1936 or 1937 mine
was over 180 i was said to have been in
the words of that man the most
intelligent child in southern poland of
course they didn't tell him anything
about that right at the time and when um
when world war
two was going to start he says during
that period i learned in a very personal
practical way i was no aryan i know that
my ancestors were jews but i knew
nothing of the mosaic faith and
regrettably nothing of
jewish culture it was only the nazi
legislation that brought home to me the
realization i had jewish blood in my
veins he talks about his childhood in
some some interesting ways here i mean
he talks about finding a bone and a
skull you know and uh breaking into his
father's bookcases and cabinets who
seems to have you know been kind of a
naughty guy right
he also says
i grew into a bookworm and read
everything that fell into my hands
the great national poems novels popular
science books
i also i can remember it looked with
keen interest that the male and female
genitalia reproduced in my father's
anatomy books that he talks about how
pornography reminds him too much of
gynecological examinations uh to be
interesting to him
he talks about being an eight-year-old
boy and falling in love with with a girl
um and he and he says may the
psychoanalysts make what they will of
the feelings of a small boy i do not
comment further
on them and he says i not only imagined
fantastic kingdoms and domains but made
inventions and mentally created
prehistoric animals unheard of in
paleontology for example i dreamed of an
aircraft shaped like a giant concave
mirror with a boiler situated in the
focus and
um
i'm going to skip forward a good bit
what we find
is that um
he you know he's he's a young man
growing up in rather chaotic
circumstances he gets the best education
that he possibly can
at the time
and um
you know he he winds up
essentially being part of
let's call it the warsaw pact the soviet
system
and um he
he runs into problems
not only from the nazis but also
from the the communists um
so a little bit later on he talks about
um here we go
um
the lysenko affair
he says
at the age of 26 i became a junior
research assistant for an organization
called the circle for the science of
science of science
uh founded by cholinowski to him i
presented my most dearly held works a
theory of brain functions invented by me
in a philosophical treatise he called
both nonsense but he took me under his
tutelage thus now this is very important
for lem's development
thus i was forced to read logic
textbooks
scientific methodologies psychology
psychometrics the history of natural
science and many other things
these books proved so interesting i had
to crack them the english books
dictionary in hand
and he says uh for the monthly uh life
of science periodical i compiled surveys
of scientific periodicals from the
standpoint of the science of science
by doing so i became involved in the
wretched lysenko affair
for in my survey i synopsized the
controversy between him and the soviet
geneticists in what an official report
from the ministry in charge of polish
universities called a tendentious manner
now you know we could say well so what
tendentious well that was a code word
for not approved and and that is uh part
of what you know set him behind
um it gets in the way of him him doing
some of the work that he'd like to do
and he's considered
rather suspect as we mentioned uh
in in other places um you know he's
he's not on the side of the authorities
right
and so
following up with the lesenko affair and
he says
i held lesenko's doctrine of the
inheritance of acquired characteristics
to be ridiculous
and i was proved right after several
years but my taking this position had
rather painful consequences for our
monthly
and you know he goes on tells us how his
father dies in in 1954 by then he's you
know writing uh quite a bit
at the end of the 50s i was able to
acquire for us myself and my wife a
small house on the southern outskirts of
krakow which we
still have
and he goes on and talks about you know
reading science fiction and writing his
own science fiction um what else do we
need to to mention you know by from 1946
onward he is writing these novels ones
that he'll say he's not very happy with
and sometimes even ashamed of them
and then he's going to
because of the fact that joseph stalin
dies
[Music]
there's there's an opening that takes
place culturally you could say within
not just russia or the united you know
the ussr
but also poland
as well
and
lem takes advantage of this this uh
significant
freedom of speech to start publishing
all sorts of stuff
he goes on and will write a number of
novels short stories
non-fiction as well so we should we
should turn to that for a moment and i
do want to bring up something that's
really quite funny
um
there's an article about lem in the
encyclopedia britannica the author of
which
william hosh says the following and i
think you know this is a good sign of
how westerners often get lem wrong
lem's renown rests primarily on three
works solaris a deeply philosophical
work about contact with an utterly alien
intelligence
he goes on to talk about the adaptations
his master's voice another classic of
traditional science fiction themes
and then finally lem's third great book
is the
siberiad subtitled fables for the
cybernetic age read on one level it's a
collection of comic tales about two
intelligent robots who travel around the
galaxy solving engineering problems a
deeper reading reveals a wealth of
profound insights into the human
condition and i think perhaps
as lem's work was getting known in the
west
that might have been true but i think
now
he's
he's better known
right so
i'm going to actually i mean he's
writing stuff from 1946 onward
and by the the 1950s
he's
starting to get very serious about the
the work that he's doing right so
we have on the one hand the
silly uh
satirical dark comedies
um connected with these heroes like you
know ijan tiki right
that we'll find as the star diaries
memoirs of a space traveler
um
[Music]
and then we have other things the
investigation a philosophical mystery
novel in which a person who's involved
doesn't even know who which agency
they're working for
and then we have eden
this is a very interesting book
what we have here is a crash landing
by a spaceship
on eden um a
planet that has a sentient life on it
and they're trying to figure out
what's go they're trying to fix their
ship for one thing and then they're
trying to figure out
what is the deal with the life here and
they they do all sorts of things
and never really get to the bottom
of the
civilization
that has developed and laid down
factories and artifacts and all sorts of
other things that still has living
representatives
in this uh
field so that's sort of a precursor of
not being able to really figure out what
the hell these
creatures are are doing
um
after that we have more you know tales
of of uh you know pricks perks the pilot
and then we have solaris 1961.
um
this is this is quite
a landmark and quite important but then
we have quite a few other
stories coming about as well memoirs
found in a bathtub the invincible that
lamb himself talks about as part of that
that period
the siberian is very important right
but also we have his master's voice the
future futurological congress and other
uh set of
ijantiki stories
and then we start getting to these
things like um
a perfect vacuum collection of a book
reviews of non-existent books rather
borehazian you could say that is
connected to uh
jorge louis borges there's more perks
the pilot stories coming out
and then we have
qatar
which is translated as the chain of
chance
and you know the stories keep going and
going and going we also have a lot of
non-fiction
as well dialogues
going into orbit
the summa technology
coming out in 64.
philosophy of chance
some other things that that find their
way into
micro worlds
and
he even tran even writes an
autobiography of his childhood before
world war ii okay called high castle a
remembrance and so you know we see lem
continually
writing straying around quite a bit
continuing his his scientific we could
call them staying abreast of the field
and
making his way through
literary fields
lem becomes quite famous his stuff
starts getting translated obviously
there's film and not just film but also
uh opera and and stage uh renditions of
some of his his works as well
and he's able to
move around
a bit when martial law is declared in
poland those who remember
the solidarity movement and all the cold
war stuff that was going on
he moves to berlin becomes a fellow of
the institute for advanced study um
settles in vienna by the time that the
translation of uh these these are coming
out he's listed as you know being in
vienna and then eventually is going to
make his way back to poland and he was
around for for quite a long time but he
but he stopped writing
novels and short stories at a certain
point and just focused on
all the other things that he wanted to
do we talked we could talk about as he
does a third phase of his work he dies
aged 84 march
2006
so about 15 years ago
after battling heart disease and leaves
behind a massive legacy one of the
interesting parts of this
is that
you know lem
[Music]
in his stories in his his speculations
manages to
predict or or think out ahead of time
things like the internet and he talks a
bit good bit about the internet at
points
and he's got a website that was
developed and you can find a lot of
resources there and so he lives on a bit
certainly past
2006 not only in our reading of him but
online
let's talk about lem's own relation to
his craft and the genre that people
would like to in his view pigeonhole him
in science fiction which he is going to
say is not just one thing it's kind of a
mishmash
of a lot of different things and it
performs different functions so i'm
going to refer quite a bit to his
interviews and i do want to begin
by looking at a a post script
on
his his interviews this comes from his
site so he's looking at these interviews
and then saying something
about them but then we'll also bring in
his own reflections
on science fiction who's good who's bad
why that's the case and about his own
writing and place in it so i want to
begin here with this
this post script
and he says quite a lot of these
questions like many of the ones i've
been receiving for the past 30 years are
based on a tacit assumption on the part
of the
writers and here it is and this is quite
insightful
that my knowledge and understanding of
my text problematic or how they came to
be or where they belong in the scheme of
things
is better than the corresponding notions
of my interlocutors in fact that it is
definitive i'm the author so therefore i
get to see where it fits in and lemon's
saying something you know quite humble
but also very realistic he's saying well
you know i've got my own ideas on this
but
i'm only one person out of so many and
it's up to you to read the works and
figure out what you think they are and
what
to make of them and so he says in
reality while i do have some knowledge
it is not the sort of knowledge that a
press correspondent possesses when
relating the course of a game
but rather the knowledge of an observer
at a printer who sees the newspapers as
they're being printed up
my answers may lead to entirely false
conclusions say that before writing
anything i had spent time considering
it's it's problematic say that before
writing solaris i intended to write
about the feudal attempts of human
contact with an alien phenomenon
attempts that end in a spectacular crash
of anthropocentrism after the depiction
of many adventures and sufferings of the
protagonists
that is indeed a good summary of the
plot of solaris is it not as well as of
eden as well as of
um
not with space travel but with you know
all sorts of other excursions his
master's voice right so these three
books and so many others of lem are
centered around that idea is that how
lem started writing these things he says
what that was not the case i didn't know
anything at first
not even that i would put some eerie
ocean on that planet
when i write the process of writing has
nothing in common with the building a
house a bottom-up activity based on a
top-down design
involving architects investors builders
and workers
both the structure of the plot and the
adventures of the characters come into
being as i write
the initial state of the book is but a
nebulous extremely
loose bunch of ideas
the final state after the writing done
is still a nebulous rather loose bunch
of ideas albeit markedly less nebulous
and less news
loose nevertheless this uncertainty
never totally shrinks away for example
even then i have no clue as to the worth
of the new work i don't know how it will
be read and understood by its various
readers whether they will be bored or
thrilled usually all my works are first
read by my wife
and very often i've gone along with her
highly critical remarks this it has also
often happened that i would not agree
with her for example when she considered
my descriptions of the library in
solaris as spurious in other works
occasionally i've had an inner certitude
that the text had to remain in its
initial form i cannot explain that
feeling and once it comes
and then he says
what may be even more surprising if not
downright paradoxical sounding this was
the way in which i wrote my discursive
prose as well no projects no blueprints
if an a priory plan was needed it often
turned out they weren't kept
it was as though i was carried away by
the current of my thought as i was
writing the text the sort of thing that
happens to white water rafters keeping
the course not really managing to do so
basically
i wrote by trial and error
yeah here we go
i wrote by trial and error and since i
never crossed out anything instead of
throwing away in its entirety what does
not please me i see myself as a high
jumper making attempts at a height one
after another each one a contained
procedure including the initial run
i usually write both horizontally and
vertically that is the initial linear
plot picks up new ideas thus widening
then i have to make over entire chapters
or more often when i'm having trouble
strike striking the right tone or
keeping the style i want i start
randomly aware that in the final tally i
can get rid of the beginning altogether
or replace it with some other
he says eventually i learned a lot from
myself for example i have on occasion
inadvertently included a reflexive
microcosm within a work
as for the fantastic technological or
scientific ideas the ones i regard as
unrealizable found their place in my
grotesque satiric and humorous writings
so this is a very important point a lot
of those are the you know even uh
ijantiki uh things right
and he goes on and and says um
on the other hand novels such as solaris
eden the invincible fiasco qatar and the
serious ones contain none
i've avoided like the plague the
problematic of time travel
traveled with infinite speed esp
psychokinesis for the simple reason i
don't believe they can really come about
similarly flying saucers show up
exclusively in my
satire
the last thing i'll read from this is he
says i consider the exercise of tax and
num
taxonomizing classifications genealogies
and literature to be a harmful brand of
scholastic activity if it is meant to
tell us how to pigeonhole work because
the most interesting issues happen to be
located on the borders of classes
especially the ones we consider sterile
that is it may appear that certain
literary species are not to be
cross-bred but i benefited greatly
from such cross breeding i hybridized
cybernetics and quantum mechanics
impregnating them with fairy tale
schemes i miss mixed kitchen scripts
with rocket tales and tiki's adventures
i have yet to come across a sci-fi
account of an astronaut with a
stomachache or the specter of a stuffed
up toilet which as we know is a major
problem with the space shuttle so
this this tells us quite a bit
is reflection on on lem's own part about
what is going on
in his work what is going on in his
writing processes and what is supposed
to be happening
with his his fiction
let's go on and look at a few other
things in these interviews that i think
could be quite interesting then we'll
then we'll talk about science fiction
more broadly so
here's something that was asked of him a
german encyclopedia calls you a
philosopher are you a philosopher what
is your opinion about the presence of
philosophy in your novels and he says
i consider it worthy to uncover what is
hidden even though i am aware of the
high risk and the inevitability of
simplifications mistakes and occasional
nonsense the reason
for many of my worries disappointments
and bewilderment bewilderments that have
not ceased yet is the fact that many
people consider
it's very important philosophizing to be
a boring and idle pursuit
well one has to be fascinated and make a
personal use of it
philosophizing should be a matter of
strong passion
those who do not feel this passion will
certainly feel disappointed by some of
my works so he's saying i'm going to
philosophize i don't have to be a
philosopher
in an academic sense i've certainly
studied enough philosophy and if you
don't get into that if you don't have
that that penchant well
that's too bad for you you're not going
to
to
have too much of it let's let's go on to
another
uh thing that he has to say
i'm going to come back to that one
so
this is in a an interview with uh
istafan cesari rani you are highly
regarded as a writer of both fiction and
experimental philosophy of science you
use fictional elements in your
philosophical works and philosophical
essayist elements in your fictions what
distinguishes these two modes for you
why don't you specialize in one or the
other and one has quite a lengthy answer
to this i'm going to read it off
in all my books both the bellatristic
and the discursive in nature all of them
were written spontaneously that is
choosing the mode of expression that
seemed most appropriate to me because it
made me write aside from essays i also
wrote three discursive books summa
technologies dialogues in science
fiction and futurology i forgot about
the fourth one the philosophy of chance
and there's nothing fantastic about them
because when writing beginning to write
each of these books i neither had a plan
nor any kind of knowledge of their
content and they basically got written
unaffected by any genealogical or
taxonomic considerations that is
i did not spend any time
thinking about the questions of what
genre
they are meant to belong to
these books contain a lot of speculation
and i'm aware of it this speculation
could be termed sui generous fantasizing
on the themes of future development
technology literature for example but i
was merely expressing my convictions
not intentionally setting up hypotheses
in this sense i functioned
as an unwitting futurologist before the
futurological gold rush itself took
place and an unwitting philosopher too
isn't that an interesting
way to talk about it he stumbles into
these areas
engaging in a kind of fantasizing but
one that's still connected to
technological and scientific realities
he says i suppose my inclination towards
armchair philosophizing was induced by
my acquaintance with certain people who
edited a philosophical journal for
example helen eilstein and
lesek kolakowski be that as it may i
never had this urge to speak my peace to
the world at large as far as philosophy
goes perhaps this disinclination comes
from my conviction this is a great line
here
that the time of crafting seamless
unified philosophical systems
is long past this is so i claim because
the results of the new hard sciences led
by physics begin to exceed the abilities
of reasoning
that's a really important point there
our previous understanding of science
has been oh well you know we come out of
the uh in in the the renaissance
uh and then in the modern period of this
era of of darkness and dogma and we know
that that history is all bs right
there's much more going on there and
there was a lot of furthering of of what
became modern science on the part of
churchmen but this idea was that science
grows by this cumulative process it's
got a method where you come up with
hypotheses and test them and there's
empiricism and we get to like you know
look at how things actually are and we
build and build and build and build and
build
and we do so through what
rationality the human capacity for
reason
lamb who's on top of the science of his
time and following along with it says
the new hard sciences
begin to exceed the abilities of
reasoning
the various events and descriptions of
states which fly in the face of visual
perception as well as other any other
human sensor intuition all that stuff
conjured by the human mind yet the sober
science marches on regis registering the
smells and colors of quarks all the
while discarding the help we naturally
owe to our bodily sensorium and lifelong
personal experience thus
if the scientific results exceed the
horizons of human intellectual
comprehension then human philosophy must
be left behind
limiting itself to reflection on the way
the world is thoroughly known to us
as a niche for certain thinking species
or to considerations of the human
position in the this world its
correctness and dangers but as science
evolves even faster negating its prior
solutions and pronouncements it's futile
to attempt to create a philosophical
system once and for all in harmony with
the effects of empirical discovery
issues such as these are what i packed
into my discursive works because i was
constantly fascinated and haunted by
them and i saw no way of including them
in my bellatristic endeavors
the fact that i did not choose one or
the other i alternated between writing
discursively and writing
bellatristically basically stems from my
human nature that of being like baking
dough my interests grow every which way
at once i would hate to give up these
using these various strategies of
relating the themes of my
life and i do want to point out that in
his master's voice contains a number of
interesting points where the main
character who is a mathematician
involved in this very important
scientific
process
while scientific project to decipher a
message has a few things to say about
about philosophy
along the way
and its capacity to help us
understand things i'm trying to track
down some of those that i've dog-eared
uh here here's a great example
he says
um given that our civilization is unable
to assimilate well even those concepts
that originate in human heads when they
appear outside its main current although
the creators of those concepts are after
all children of the same age
how could we have assumed that we would
be capable of understanding a
civilization totally unlike ours if it
addressed us across the cosmic gulf the
metaphor of an army of tiny little
creatures that put to good use their
encounter with the corpse of a
philosopher still seems to me
quite fitting
and he talks about the myth of our
cognitive
universality right
and he says you know
philosophers might assume
that they can actually figure all these
things out but they they really need to
be paying attention to what the
sciences uh reveal to us and very often
what the science has revealed to us is
we don't know what the hell we're doing
we're kind of stabbing around in the
dark and you know hopefully bringing to
bear our our notions that can help
illuminate things and that's about as
good as it gets
um there's a few other things that i do
want to to bring up
talking about critics and criticism
we
find out that uh he here we go how do
you deal with critics what sort of
critique do you prefer
for contemporary novels and he says
my experiences with western critics are
bad because of many misunderstandings
and misconceptions this changed only
after good critics started to deal with
my works those in the highest domain in
my fields
previously critics read my works as if
they tried to find a recipe for donuts
in a telephone book hence they were
dissatisfied and rejected my books
now here's where he says something
really interesting i was aware polemics
and discussion are simply futile how
would that look like
it is not true as critic x says that my
book is dedicated to the matter why it
is dedicated to the matter z
these are simply grand misunderstandings
currently one can observe the same
situation in reverse
in a number of reviews which follow each
of my books just like a tale follows a
comment one can read trite praise which
means that the given critic is convinced
he has to do with a quote good and
praiseworthy product however he's not
really sure what the book is really
about there are about a dozen critics in
the entire world who are both experts in
the field of critique and modern science
without knowledge of science one cannot
comment on my works how is an ignoramus
to know whether the presented concept is
my idea an extrapolation or final
conclusions from the actual
scientifically established facts you
notice it's important for him that
science fiction has the science side
right
although one writes for the readers one
would like the critic to be a genius who
puts his thermometer into a given text
and reads the exact temperature however
this was not the case
in the west there's nothing more scary
than a novel with an intellectual
content
so
isn't that a great one-liner there
that he's bringing up i think that
that's that's quite awesome right um a
little bit uh later in the set of
interviews
he talks about um
again critics and and readers and he
says something quite interesting here
i know more or less how the critics read
me because obviously he can read what
the critics are saying
i know nothing about how i'm received by
my readers
the ones who do not busy themselves with
public critiquing
my roots are at least twofold in
bellatristic writing and in hard
sciences and philosophy
to account for who influenced me in
terms of individual writers is a feat
beyond me i don't know how much i owe to
whom
to tell the truth i never thought about
it i can say
however that my attitude as a reader to
various authors has changed a lot over
time there was a time when i admired uh
with whitekewich
now i'm unable to read through his stuff
it's philosophizing irks me now with its
pretentiousness it's baroque stylizing
when describing the spiritual now turns
me off the whole now seems to me the
work of a child prodigy had snotty
people who managed to get a hold of some
lessons before his time and made
mincemeat out of it and here he talks
about several other
writers i haven't read kafka for a long
time because there's something in his
works i find repugnant
it's as though they contain more
misfortune than is proper for a decent
author it's as if kafka struggled with
both some real forces and some that were
but his own personal desperate neuroses
and i despise writer psychopaths
of dostoyevsky's works
only crime and punishment was compelling
enough to make me come back to it
although he also talks about
the underground man later as well as for
the brothers karmazov and the possessed
i was unable to read them again a single
pass was entirely
sufficient why i don't know
and we we go on he says i respect joseph
conrad preferring his short stories to
lord jim and
nostromo i am overall not a studious
reader of bellatristic literature i
can't say why
i used to love bold lair deteron swift
lately i tend to return to well-known
poetry instead he brings up slowaki
lyman and raynor maria
rilka so this is uh some some quite
interesting remarks that he's making on
these topics we should turn now to what
he has to say about science fiction and
i'm going to bring up something from
some tale uh
technology i almost said teologia right
he's uh talking about
um
science fiction
and it's part in helping us think about
is there other life in the universe and
he says
the idea of starting a new chapter in
our investigations one extended to the
whole of the universe is appealing as
well as dangerous
what distinguishes us from lower beings
as that is animals
is not only our civilization but also an
awareness of our own limitations the
greatest of which is mortality
we have no idea in what way beings
higher than us exceed us in any case we
must emphasize what interests us our
facts and their interpretation in
accordance with the scientific
principles not fantasy work this is why
we shall not be taking into account any
of those countless futures that have
been prophesied for the earth and for
some other celestial bodies by writers
who occupy themselves with this rather
prolific genre called science fiction
as we know it is not literature's habit
to use scientific methods or apply
mathematical and methodological
principles or probability theory not
even when it comes to science fiction
literature i'm not saying this to accuse
science fiction of betraying the
scientific truth only to emphasize how
important it is for us to distance
ourselves from any kind of arbitrariness
we shall be drawing an observational
material from astrophysics and on the
method followed by the scientist which
has very little in common with the
artist's method
it is not because the latter would be
more inclined to take risks than the
former but only because the scientists
ideal the complete isolation of what he
aims to represent from the world of his
own experiences the purification of the
objective facts conclusions from any
subjective emotions is foreign to the
artist in other words the closer one
gets to being a scientist the more one
silences one's humanity to allow nature
to speak as it were the more of an
artist one becomes in turn the more this
artist imposes himself on us with all
the greatness and frailty of his unique
being
this is a wonderful way of expressing
this continuum with the scientists over
here the artist over here
most of the science fiction writers over
here as well and the philosopher
somewhere in this case not saying
anything in between and lem bounces back
and forth between these you know as i
as i read to you earlier he will
introduce things like aliens that we can
encounter and have a future logical
congress with but that's just for this
that's true laughs right that's that's
joking around that's over here on this
end that's the bellatristic thing that
he's been talking about and then way
over on the other end of the spectrum we
would in fact have stories like
solaris or
in his master's voice or any of these
other ones along those lines
we also need to look at what he has to
say about science fiction
in this wonderful
set of essays in micro worlds so lem
to put it very bluntly was not a fan of
the science fiction genre because he
thought that much of it was
quite garbage
he begins in science fiction a hopeless
case with exceptions by talking about uh
damon knight's really great book in
search of wonder which is a set of
essays of criticism on science fiction
and he says
in science fiction fandom rumor has that
science fiction is improving every year
if so why does the average production
the lion's share of new productions
remain so bad
right that's a important question and he
says the important question is even if
science fiction were born in the gutter
and lived on trash for years on end why
can't it get rid of the trash for good
and he says my essay attempts to answer
these questions therefore it is a
prologumenon
to science fiction ecology
or an introduction to a social
socioculturally isolated realm of
creative work or a practical guide for
survival in the lower realm of
literature so these are some really
great
and as he says pompous titles right
and
what's he saying to justify that so he
starts out by saying
science fiction is a collective
phenomenon of a socio-cultural nature
it has the following parts the readers
on the one hand the mute and passive
majority of science fiction consumers on
the other the active amateur groups that
constitute fandom proper so that's the
the audience right and then the science
fiction producers authors some of them
also critics and publishers of magazines
and works and he says science fiction is
a very special case because it belongs
to two distinct spheres of culture
the lower realm or realm of trivial
literature and the upper realm or realm
of mainstream literature
to the lower realm
in his time he says
belong the crime novel the western the
pseudo-historical novel the sports novel
and the erotico sentimental stories
about certain locations like doctor
nurse romances millionaire and the
playgirl stories and so on
so he
he says i'd like to spare the reader a
detailed description of what i mean by
the mainstream let me just quote you
some authors
um who inhabit this olympus joyce
boutour sartre grass mailer borjes
calvino you know and he goes on and on
including graham green
and he says
it cannot be maintained with universal
validity these authors do not descend to
the lower floors occasionally we know of
crime novels by graham greene fantastic
novels by orwell and you know other
things like that some texts by calvino
are even considered science fiction and
he says
i want to propose a practical rule
procedure which will predict with 98
accuracy whether an author will be
considered as an inhabitant of the upper
lower floor
if someone starts to write in the
mainstream and the public and critics
get to know him by name or even as a
world celebrity
his attempts at science fiction and
fantasy are regarded as excursions or
side leaps and that man lives on the
upper floor so the entertainments of
graham greene
are that and he says now going back
to h.g wells time there wasn't such a
clear-cut border between these two
realms of literature and wells could
move between them
and he talks about um
trivial literature
here's some interesting things to think
about
it says the status of trivial literature
can be recognized by several attributes
its works are read only once just like
the cheapest mass products
intended just for a single use so if
you're reading
crap science fiction
you read it it was cool you're not going
to go back to it unless of course you're
the kind of person who's like mindlessly
ruminates on things over and over and
over again right
so
there's a constant need to churn he says
also i must remark a reader of trivial
literature behaves just like the
consumer of mass products
surely it does not occur to the producer
brooms cars or toilet paper to complain
of the absence of correspondence fraught
without pourings of the soul that
strikes a connection between him and the
consumer of his products sometimes
however these consumers happen to write
angry letters to the producer to
reproach him with the bad quality of the
merchandise they bought
this bears a striking similarity to what
james blish describes in the issue at
hand and indeed this author more than
five million of whose books have been
printed said that he received only some
dozens of letters from readers during
his whole life as author these letters
were exclusively fits of temper from
people who were hurt in the soft spot of
their opinion it was the quality of the
goods that offended them so that's
another sign of trivial literature right
third the market of trivial literature
knows only one index of quality
the measure of the sales figures of the
books right so this is quite important
and he says
if we use this yardstick
dostoyevsky is no match for agatha
christie
there are many fans of science fiction
who've never ever
read a novel by stapleton or wells in
their lives and with an easy mind i can
assert the silent majority of readers
does not even know olaf stapleton by
name right bliss and knight agree the
public cannot distinguish a good novel
from an abominable novel with the
provisional that they're talking only
about the leaders the readers of the
lower realm
finally he says
fourth there are crass and embarrassing
differences between the relations that
link the authors of the upper and lower
realm of publishers
in the upper realm it's the
author who alone determines the style
length form and style of his the title
length forms style of his work and he
has the right to do so guaranteed
unequivocally by the letter of his
contract in the lower realm the
publishers appropriate these rights and
this this leads to what he's going to
talk about in terms of philip k dick as
a
example of somebody who's writing good
science fiction sometimes not not all of
dick's work is good science fiction
according to to blish but who's being
forced into these construct constraints
and
limitations of the lower world as a
matter of fact we know that dick wrote
some really wonderful realistic novels
like milk and lumke territory or
um
you know
the uh
the humpty dumpty one i'm blanking on
the name really great stuff and the
publishers would not publish it because
he'd been pigeonholed as a sci-fi author
so skipping ahead
right
he says that there's this big
distinction between the upper and lower
realm and people are trying to push
their way up into it but instead they're
stuck in this science fiction
ghetto
and he says that you know
quite understandably a lot of the
science fiction stuff is not
particularly
good and isn't going to make it out of
there
and there's really two big issues
literary quality
but also the fact that it's not really
science fiction it's more science
fantasy
and the science stuff in there is being
used in ways that can't really be
supported right
he brings up uh the exception philip k
dick and he says because of the lack of
selection process to struggle against
trash and promote real value the works
of dick are sometimes compared with
those of a event vote
the novels of both authors share common
characteristics that one they are
composed of trashy parts and two they're
full of contradictory elements the
contradictions include those of an
external nature as when the world
depicted in a book runs counter to
empirical scientific knowledge and in of
an internal nature as when during the
course of a novel the action becomes
self-denying that is contradicts itself
he says such a diagnosis does not
automatically invol invoke a subsequent
condemnation
right so he's actually willing to
reel out some strings so to speak and he
says
as knight and bliss have proved the
phantasmagoric acrobatics of van vote do
not add up to a meaningful whole
he does not solve the riddles posed he
does not draw conclusions from the
things depicted early in his books
he sketches only ephemeral ideas piling
them chaotically on one another with all
that he does not hypnotize the weary
reader but only lulls him to sleep this
sleep comes from increasing boredom not
fascinating magnetism now isn't that an
interesting distinction what a wonderful
way to cut right through it right
hypnotism and magnetism induced by the
work
soperific dull boring stuff and they can
both be produced by the same
basic thing which is contradictions
so he says
um
philip k dick seems to write in a vein
similar to van votes although he does
not like van vote violate grammar and
syntax as well as physics dick 2 works
with trash yet his novels are structured
with more logic he has a custom to let
action issue from a clearly and
precisely built situation
only later in the course of an uh
in the course of a novel does decay
perplexing the reader begin to undermine
initial disorder so that the end of the
novel becomes a single knot of fantasies
dreaming and waking are mixed reality
becomes indistinguishable from
hallucination and the intangible center
of dick's world dissolves into a series
of quivering
mocking monstrosities so that in the end
each novel of dick's mainstream for dick
has also written second-rate
insignificant works
destroys the order of things he erected
at the beginning and he's going to give
some examples here
if even if dick's world's older
explosion to a technology or a disease
or madness of the space-time manifold at
an ever-increasing speed they multiply
their suitor realities so that as in
this three-stigmata of palmer eldritch
the levels of hallucination and reality
which were separate from each other
become a space-time labyrinth
but
dick always moves among the typical
trash of science fiction in the realm of
androids of the usual prophets precogs
psi esp fields brain transplants and
hundreds of other similarly scurrilous
products and phenomena trash is present
everywhere in dick's books from time to
time though in some of his novels he
succeeds in executing a master stroke he
has invented an extremely refined tactic
he uses elements of trash
that is those degenerate molecules that
once had a sacramental metaphysical
value
so that he leads to a gradual
resurrection of the long extinct
metaphysical exotic values in a way he
makes trash battle against trash he does
not deny it he does not throw it away
but he builds from it a ladder that
leads straight into that horrible heaven
which during this operation ceases to be
an orthodox heaven but does not become
an orthodox hell
this is so interesting right because if
you look at what lem is trying to do in
his own works and he's going to talk
about ubik is a really great example of
dick's work and then a little bit later
he's got you know pk dick a vic a
visionary among the charlatans and
singles out ubik again
you know
lem is not writing quite the way that
dick is lem is more on the
you know let's keep the science uh keep
things within the realm of scientific
possibility let's not bring in any of
this crazy uh you know
too easy stuff right and instead um he's
willing to say that dick is on to
something and you could say a similar
thing about borehase who he devotes an
entire
essay 2 here as well
towards the the end of of the book and
you know that's well worth
looking at although i think we're going
to we're going to maybe skip over it
right now in part because i want to save
plenty of time for talking about
philosophical themes but what we see
here is
lem is you know very suspicious of
the
science fiction industry
thinking that it's not particularly
good stuff in general
and that there's a few exceptions and
those exceptions
are going to have two main features to
them they they you know in some way try
to engage with actual science and are
informed by it or if they don't do that
they are fitting into
the things that really great literature
does but the vast field as far as he's
concerned is is mostly direct mostly
commercial regurgitated stuff
that isn't really worth reading so
you know what do we say about
his own works does this have any
implication for
his stuff he's you know he's willing to
as we remarked with these interviews
leave that up to us to figure out as
not critics
but readers
let's turn our attention now to the
novel solaris in particular and before
we
look at some of the key philosophical
themes that are being developed in there
some of which lamb tells us this is what
i was actually
doing in this work let's check out the
book as a whole
and also look again at some some things
that he says in interviews and in essays
about this this work and what he what he
was aiming at in doing it what kind of
writing it is and so
i think that maybe the place to begin is
actually with the book itself
um
we'll come back to the cover of this in
just a moment so
what is the narrative universe
that solaris belongs in it's a universe
that on the one side is that of human
beings going out to the stars
solaris has been around
and explored for quite some time
generation after generation enough for
there to be
a massive
library
which gets its own chapter
in the work um the solarists right and
it's it's there's some really great
descriptions there that we're going to
go into when we talk about the notions
of of libraries
and solaris itself is a planet out there
in space one of many planets that is
being explored some of which are being
exploited by human beings
and there's something there that
people think is
it's definitely life the question is is
it intelligent life and if so
what what kind of thoughts does it think
and
is it
something that we human beings can have
a connection or even communication with
this ocean
that produces
amazing forms
within it you know generating them out
of itself
and also is going to be producing
whatever we want to call them simulacra
of people that the researchers on the
solaris station which is where all
almost all of the action takes place the
very beginning is like getting to the
solaris station
and then there's you know um setting
foot on solaris itself when when the
main character
is about to leave
calvin and
in the meantime
you know the bulk of what's happening is
on the station
and it's the interplay between the human
beings
the simalacra and this
vast
ocean that surrounds the entire
planet um so
we're going to get into talking a little
bit more about this
um you could say that the plot of it is
essentially
as has often been summarized the human
beings attempt to connect with
the ocean and then to deal with what the
ocean has generated in response to them
it's an attempt to try to make sense out
of things both theoretically
and practically now a lot of people
in
lem's view
took the wrong
point of view it took the wrong
set of themes
from the work and so here is where we
can get to talking about the
film adaptations which we're not going
to go into very much
and you'll see why in just a moment so
this this particular picture is taken
from the more recent american adaptation
of it with george clooney as the star
and lem was not actually
a great fan
of what was happening with with this um
movie
and with um
the stories so
there's um
here we go
um
i'm gonna come back to this this one in
a moment was here's a question that was
asked of him was andre tarkovsky in
touch with you as he was producing the
film solaris what is your opinion about
the films by andre tarkowski and steven
soderbergh do you agree with the changes
with with which the directors made in
your story so this is like lem's pretty
much definitive
viewpoint on it he says
tarkovsky was crazy about the idea of
filming solaris during those times he
was told by a number of high-ranking
members of the soviet communist party
one should not film this book because
the work is ideologically flawed
idealistic subjective metaphysical now
there's a whole other other story to be
told about that it's very funny that
somebody would say that idealistic about
this book right
i mean it is subjective and metaphysical
however he would not listen to them
because tarkovsky was entirely made up
of this idealistic metaphysical stuff
mixed with a russian soul hence he was
not a good addressee of such warnings
i have serious reservations regarding
his film adaptation
firstly
i would like to see the planet solaris
secondly
during one of our arguments i told
tarkovsky
that he
never made solaris but crime and
punishment instead
from this film we gather that this
horrible kelvin guy would lead poor hari
to suicide and later had some remorse
about it well the latter was
strengthened by her reappearance in
strange and incomprehensible
circumstances so that that's part of the
book right
the hari shows up and is that one of the
simulacra right and we know from the
book that um because of
uh
because of calvin's
essentially cruelty and and indifference
to her
she overdoses on medication and kills
herself and so that that is a uh
something that's that's there but then
what is what does tarkovsky do
what was awful just awful the
introduction of kelvin's parents and an
aunt his mother was the worst since this
was a russian mott i.e rodina the mother
earth this really angered me a lot
at that point we were like two horses
dragging the same cart in different
directions
here's where he says something really
people's lives
that we get to know at the station are
no existentialist anecdotes
but grand questions concerning the place
of humans in the cosmos
my calvin decides to stay at the planet
without any hope well tarkovsky created
a vision with some island and a hut i'm
quite irritated by this image i cannot
stand the emotional gravy in which
tarkovsky submerged my heroes not to
mention the fact that he entirely was
very important entirely removed the
scientific landscape of the planet
and replaced it by a number of
eccentricities
i can tell you very little
he goes on about soderberg's remake i
hear that critics perceive it as derived
from tarkovsky from the financial point
of view the movie certainly was a
spectacular
fiasco so he's he's not happy with
something that the
filmmaker is doing which is leaving out
the real philosophy stuff in there and
substituting other stuff
instead and that is
you know that is a significant problem
in lem's view um dealing with with this
right so
we'll come back to the other parts in a
bit
um
he also discusses this
in
another point
so
one of the other interviews says
according to aquinas the other
somologist right because we're talking
about this book the summa technology
amor este agues cognitive
talking about love and it being this
this
positive uh cognitive force it's a
striking characteristic of your work
that you don't depict affectionate
relationships among your protagonists at
least since solaris and returned from
the stars some theorists have made
persuasive arguments that cognition is
an extra
and inextricably tied to certain kinds
of affections and that the western
tradition of purifying the intellect
involves a refusal to give value to
emotional relationships in the world
actually solaris might be read as
depicting exactly this state of affairs
since the solaris as soon as they
encounter the alien planet are suddenly
brought face to face with the emotional
lives they've replied repressed
you seem to have left this theme behind
so much so that your golem to passion
dispassionately dismisses love is this
lack of a more or love in your work a
conscious strategy
so lem says
love is a matter of individuals it is
the fulfillment of the human psyches
expectations
an individual is able to feel love only
towards a small number of the closest
persons be it erotic love parental other
for example religiously inspired in my
private life this emotion plays perhaps
the main role but one cannot really love
humanity
it is impossible even to get to know all
coexisting
persons so put love of humanity as a
pure abstraction entirely impotent in
the face of the world's dramatic
problems
this is why making love the subject of
the book is tantamount to closing one's
eyes to the problems of the world
and because of this alone it would hinge
on being escapist of course these are
strictly my private convictions
i don't believe love can save nations or
entire societies that may be why love
has taken the back seat
in my writing
and it's interesting because when he
does talk about soderbergh
later on
he is going to
criticize
the fact that soderbergh
wanted to emphasize the love
relationship and
just like
his other you know uh predecessor
tarkovsky
is leaving out important themes
i'm not sure i can find the reference
here in it but i'll i'll summarize it
for you
lem says
that um what he's done writing this book
is create you know a vast uh
river
and that soderbergh chose to explore
only certain tributaries leaving the
other stuff out so what's what's
actually
being left out we could call them some
cosmic
themes some philosophical themes i mean
love is a philosophical theme obviously
but
some philosophical themes that are
really quite important for
understanding
um
what lem is
trying to do what he's able to bring out
in this work one one part of it is as
the crit as he was criticizing
you don't get to see solaris
and the ocean
in
uh tarkovsky's work and you know a good
bit of
um what's happening in here
is is discussions about the amazing
things that are happening
in this ocean these vast
um
[Music]
projections out of it that are being
created each one you know different
than the other
uh and and
sort of trying to figure out what they
are
there's also important themes about not
just love but
the nature of these
sentient beings that
we're calling simulacra
that are
generated
somehow
by the
the ocean and who are engaging with
these characters perhaps as a mode of
communication
or a way of investigating them
that's really an important theme but
there's other super important themes as
well that got unfortunately left out in
the movies and this is why lem was not
not a particular fan you could say that
looking back at
his distinction between like you know
the really good science fiction and the
stuff that schlock the movies
are becoming schlock
in his view
we do learn a bit as well uh from his
his uh reflections on my life about how
this this particular book and some of
the other books fit in with each other
um he he tells us that
in in these years um we're talking about
the 50s and 60s i was particularly well
informed about the latest developments
in the various science
um the krakovian circle function is the
kind of clearinghouse for scientific
literature coming from the united states
and to some degree from canada coming to
all the polish universities from the
book parcels i received i could borrow
all the works that
stirred my interest including veneers
the human use of human beings at night i
read everything voraciously so i could
pass the books on as soon as possible to
the people who were supposed to get them
on the basis of this reading i wrote
those of my novels that i can still
notice this phrase acknowledge without
shame
eden
solaris the invincible and so on
they incorporate
cognitive problems in fictions that do
not oversimplify the world
as did my earliest naive science fiction
novels so this is among books that are
not oversimplifying the world right
a little bit later he says
[Music]
my earliest novels which i acknowledge
is my own only with some discomfort i
planned and constructed according to a
complete design
i wrote the novels in the solaris group
in a similar manner which i myself
cannot explain
the terminology of birth i've used above
may sound inappropriate but it's
somewhat apt i'm still able to point to
passages
in solaris and return from the stars
where i found myself during the writing
process in the position of a reader
isn't that an interesting thing to say
when calvin the narrator of solaris
arrives at the station hovering over the
planet solaris and finds it empty of
human beings and when he starts his
search for the crew and encounters the
scientist snow who goes into a state of
panic
i had no idea why anybody had expected
his arrival or why snow behaved in this
peculiar manner indeed i had no idea at
all that some living ocean would cover
the whole planet all this was divulged
to me in the same manner that it becomes
clear to the reader
in the course of reading the book with
the sole difference that it was i who
created the
novel
[Music]
he calls the period in which he wrote
solaris his second period
and he says that
to create something radically new it was
necessary to advance into another field
of possibilities
i believe that in the first period of my
career i wrote purely secondary things
in the second period solaris the
invincible
i reached the borders of a field that
was already mapped
in the third period when i wrote for
example reviews of non-existent books
and forwards to works that as i put it
ironically in an interview would be
published sometime in the future but
that do not exist yet i left the fields
already exploited and broke new
ground so
what is happening in terms of of solaris
well it's
it's going beyond what he was doing in
his earlier works that he he he would
disavow if he could
but it's still remaining within the
realm of science fiction and it's not
something like a soma
technology
which is which is going a bit um
well certainly it's not science fiction
it's a different sort of thing
and you know i think if we look at
solaris um
you know especially if we look at the
last chapter
which he talks about writing about a
year
later
um
he says that he was a prisoner in his
nightmares
and and you know
reya is still there
and then eventually
she's going to be
gone
right
he says i do not remember the exact
sequence of events after that as i
stumbled half naked through the length
and breadth of the station
i came to my sense
senses again lying on a metal table
and she asked he asked snow where is she
she's not here but rhea rhea is dead she
will come back i whispered
instead of dreading her return i wanted
it i did not attempt to remind myself
why i myself had once tried to drive her
away and why i'd been so afraid of her
return
and snow says no no no we've
we've used a machine and she's gone
we've dispelled her we'll write a report
later on we'll ask for an immediate link
with the council
the planet will no longer be subject to
the four power convention will be used
to auth will be authorized to use any
means at our disposal
and snow essentially wants to to destroy
things and
um
you know they talk a bit more
and there's some some back and forth
discussion with them
um
[Music]
here actually here's the very final bet
i sat by the panoramic window looking at
the ocean there was nothing to do that
now that the report which had taken five
days to compile was only a pattern of
waves in space it would be months before
a similar pattern would leave earth to
create its own line of disturbance in
the gravitational field of the galaxy
towards the twin suns of solaris
and he goes on and he says there were
several months to go before i could
leave i could watch the birth of the
days
watch the memoids uh arising
the uh
the
different
uh fluid forms that that are that are
developing
and he says
what does earth mean to me what does
that word mean
i thought of the great bustling cities
where i would wander and lose myself i
thought of them as i thought of the
ocean on the second or third night when
i'd wanted to throw myself on the dark
waves i shall immerse myself among men
i'll be silent and attentive an
appreciative companion there will be
many acquaintances friends women perhaps
even a wife for a while i shall have to
make a conscious effort to smile not
stand and perform the thousands of
little gestures which constitute life on
earth and then those gestures will
become reflexes again
i will find new interests and
occupations
i will not give myself completely to
them as i shall never again give myself
completely to anybody
or anything
and he goes on a little bit further they
have a very interesting discussion about
about god that we can look at perhaps
later
and then it ends with him
um taking a helicopter and flying to
an island that's within this and he says
i flew past the island slowly yard by
yard i descended to the level of the
eroded peaks the mimoid was not large it
measured about three quarters of a mile
from end to end it was a few hundred
yards wide in some places it was close
to splitting apart
on the scale of solaris it was only a
tiny splinter weeks or perhaps months
old
i found a beach
and then
the rotors almost hit a cliff that
reared up suddenly my path but i landed
safely cut the motor and slid back the
canopy
standing on the fuselage i made sure
there was no chance of the flitter
sliding into the ocean
um the cliff i had almost hit was a huge
bony membrane pierced with holes he goes
to that and then
he says it was like looking at the ruins
of an ancient town a moroccan city tens
of centuries old convulsed by an
earthquake or some other disaster so
he's moving around the memoir this part
the thing that the ocean has brought
forth and
it ends by saying
during the last week i had been behaving
so normally snow had stopped keeping a
watchful eye on me on the surface i was
calm
in secret without really admitting it i
was waiting for something her return how
could i have been waiting for that
we all know we are material creatures
subject to the laws of physiology and
physics and not even the power of our
feelings combined can defeat those laws
all we can do is to test them
right the age-old faith of lovers and
poets and the power of love stronger
than death that phoenix vitae said
non-amoris
is a lie useless and not even funny
and he goes on and says
that liquid giant had been the death of
hundreds of men the entire human race
had tried in vain to establish even the
most tenuous link with it and it bore my
weight without noticing me any more than
it would notice a speck of dust
i did not believe it could respond to
the tragedy of two human beings yet its
activities did have a purpose true i was
not absolutely certain but leaving would
mean giving up a chance perhaps an
infinitesimal one perhaps only
imaginary must i go on living here then
among the objects we had both touched in
the air she had breathed in the name of
what in the hope of her return i hoped
for nothing and yet i lived in
expectation
since she had gone that was all that
remained i did not know what
achievements what mockery
even what tortures still awaited me i
knew nothing and i persisted in the
faith that the time of cruel miracles
was not passed what a wonderful
ending that leaves everything in
suspension we don't know what's going to
happen with this
ocean world this
vast creature
of unknown intelligence we don't know
what earth is going to do we don't know
if he's if he's really going to go back
to earth or or not
and
so you know this this world that has
been sketched out for the purposes of
this book still remains a largely
unexplored and equivocal though
certainly investigated and speculated
about
environment
and entity
there are a number of key philosophical
themes that i'd wanted to discuss in
length but this video is already getting
a little bit long
so i'm going to collapse them all into
one
rather far-ranging
discussion and these are themes that are
found
not just in the novel solaris but also
in
you know things like the uh soma
technology and discussing
um alien life and whether we'd be able
to understand them the common theme that
comes up as well and these two novels
his master's voice eden and in other
lemian
novels
so what are the these big key themes one
i've just mentioned the
impossibility
of really establishing
contact it's possible to have first
contact to know that there's
something there and that it seems to be
intelligent but to
figure out how to connect to communicate
that's what turns out to be beyond
the capacities of human beings and human
rationality
as lem
wants to say and notice that this isn't
for
failure of trying or applying different
ideas we'll get into that in a moment
another key thing that that comes up in
solaris is
these um
people
who are you know sentient beings
have
characteristics they're not completely
blank slates
that are connected with the the
astronauts who are
checking out and trying to understand
solaris after so many generations of
research
and again this has to do with the
attempt to make contact they engage in
an unauthorized and novel experiment of
more aggressive engagement with this
ocean this sentient ocean
and
the ocean sends back in ways that we
don't really know in ways in which the
beings themselves don't know these
simulacra of people who are important in
the
the astronauts lives
and you know these are
people who are
you know produced on a very different
material basis right and in some
respects they could be immortal
but
they struggle with the same human
condition that the rest of us do what
are we how the hell did we get here what
are we supposed to be doing all these
big as you know
lem derided them as existential
questions but they really and he said
there are bigger questions than that
they really are existential questions
and so
um there aren't any answers provided
a third really important theme i think
is the
development of libraries of speculation
research pseudoscience all of these
things surrounding the problems
that we we run into
in these stories and of course the
fourth big theme would be this this
notion
of the sentient ocean which we'll get to
in just a bit and i actually like to
begin by talking about the library thing
and we'll begin with not talking about
solaris itself but rather the later his
master's voice
this is in the very first chapter
the master's voice project has an
enormous literature more extensive and
diverse than ever had the manhattan prod
project upon its public disclosure
america and the world were inundated
with articles treaties and essays so
numerous that the bibliography alone is
a tremendous tome as thick as an
encyclopedia the official version is the
ballon report which the american library
later published in 10 million copies but
the essence of it appears in the eighth
volume of the encyclopedia americana and
there have been books about the project
by others who held high positions in it
such as rapaports the first interstellar
communication dills inside his master's
voice or protheros hmv the implications
for
physics and he goes out and says there
are too many historical treatises even
to mention in a separate category are
books not factual but interpretive
ranging from the philosophical and
theological even to the psychiatric the
reading of such publications never fails
to weary and annoy me it is no
coincidence i am sure that those who
have the most to say about the project
are the ones who have had no direct
contact with it and later on he talks
about graphomania and this is quite
interesting because the same thing shows
up in the literature about solaris this
planet and its ocean
in in that he says that um you know
there's this these volumes in the
library there's um some summarization
of the experiments and he says um
compared with the proliferation of
speculative ideas which were triggered
off by this problem medieval
scholasticism seemed a model of
scientific enlightenment
the second part of this second volume of
hughes and oigle
nearly 1500 pages long was devoted
exclusively to the bibliography of the
subject there would not have been enough
room for the books themselves in the
cabin in which i was sitting and he
summarizes these i'll i'm not going to
try to read too much of of this
i'll just hit on a few interesting
high notes of it he says
um
we have we have some sort of
mathematical hypotheses underestimating
the resources of the human mind bowing
to the unknown proclaiming the ancient
doctrine arrogantly resurrected of
ignoramus at ignorama bimos uh we don't
know and we won't know others regarded
the mathematician's hypotheses as
sterile and dangerous nonsense
contributing to the creation of modern
mythology based on the notion of a giant
brain yet others the but the would-be
experts were legion and each had their
own theory a comparison of the contact
school of thought with other branches of
solaris studies notice that solaris
studies during the last quarter of a
century made it clear that a solaris
cybernetician had difficulty in making
himself understood to a solarist
symmetriologist
um
how do you expect me to you know
communicate with the ocean where you
can't understand one another
so you know how how are they going to
understand this phenomenon of the
intelligence to some degree ocean
and he says gradually in scientific
circles the solaris affair came to be
regarded as a lost cause notably among
administrators of the institute where
voices had recently been raised
suggesting financial support should be
withdrawn and research suspended no one
until then had declared dared to suggest
the final liquidation of the station and
then he goes many people in the world of
science however especially among the
young had unconsciously come to regard
the affair as a touchstone of individual
values and he goes through all these
different hypotheses that the ocean is
basically like a yogi
or that it's um you know
all sorts of other interesting things
and nobody knows nobody actually
understands but the writing of books has
no and and it's to the degree that
nobody could master that literature even
if bibliographies
are possible now it's centered on this
this ocean that we know uh in the story
is
doing something it's
thinking something it's producing
something and there's actually you know
lots of descriptions of that here's
one of them
genius and mediocrity alike are
dumbfounded by the teeming diversity of
the oceanic formations of solaris no man
has ever become genuinely conversant
with them
geese was by no means a mediocrity nor
was he a genius he was a scholarly
classifier the type whose compulsive
application to their work utterly
divorces them from the pressures of
everyday life he devised a plain
descriptive terminology supplemented by
terms of his own invention although
these were inadequate and sometimes
clumsy it has to be admitted no semantic
system is yet available to illustrate
the behavior of the ocean the tree
mountains extensors fungoids mismoids
symmetriads and asymmetries vertebrates
and agolus are artificial linguistically
awkward terms but they do give some
impression of solaris to anyone who has
only seen the planet and blurred
photographs in incomplete films so you
know nobody actually
knows what this ocean is doing or all
these different interesting formations
so vast that you can land a helicopter
in them and explore them some of them
lasting for
weeks on end
maybe the an attempt for the the ocean
to communicate with us perhaps it's just
something the ocean does to amuse itself
nobody actually can make sense of this
clearly
alien life and so that brings us to the
the key idea right
in solaris it is essentially the
vast cosmic well
earthbound ocean
that is the alien we we cannot make any
useful contact with and we can't
understand it right so a little bit
later in the book
one of the characters says
contact with the ocean as i see it the
problem is basically very simple contact
means the exchange
of specific knowledge ideas or at least
of findings definite facts but what if
no exchange is possible
if an elephant is not a giant microbe
the ocean is not a giant brain obviously
there can be various approaches and the
consequence of one of them so he's
talking to
his simulacrum
is that you are here now with me and i'm
trying my hardest to make you realize
that i love you just your being here
cancels out the 12 years of my life that
went into the study of solaris and i i
want to keep you and then now he's
talking and trying to give her some idea
about
what's her purpose
you may have been sent to torment me or
to make my life happier or an instrument
ignorant of its function used like a
microscope with me on the slide
possibly your here is a token of
friendship or a subtle punishment or
even a joke it could be all of those at
once or which is more probable something
else entirely
if you say our future depends on the
ocean's intentions i can't deny it i
can't tell the future any more than you
can i can't even swear that i always
will love you
after what has happened we can expect
anything suppose tomorrow it turns me
into a green jellyfish it's out of our
hands
so
not only can the researchers not
make effective contact with the ocean
they can't even supply answers to these
people
that have been created by the ocean
about what their their point or purpose
is
with a similar problem coming up in eden
right a ship crash lands a ship composed
of a number of different experts using
robots and and things like that and
there is a civilization or perhaps
several civilizations on eden
and a number of different kinds of
aliens they appear to be involved in
some sort of
war or struggle with each other but it's
they're never able to figure out
how to really relate with them and they
do have quite a bit of contact
and one of the the characters the
engineer says
i think we should leave
everyone looked at him with astonishment
he went on i felt differently before
it's a question of the price just the
price
undoubtedly we could learn much more
but the cost of obtaining that knowledge
knowledge of these aliens their
civilization their history
it might be too great for both sides
after what has happened the possibility
of peaceful contact of coming to an
understanding is it seems to me
extremely remote each of us whether we
like it or not has his own concept of
the world of this world mine was the
terrible things were going on here and
we should intervene
as long as we were robinson caruso's
going through our wreckage and making
repairs i said nothing i wanted to wait
until i knew more and until we could
make use of our machines but i i see now
each intervention on behalf of what we
hold to be good and right
will end the way our last excursion did
with the use of the annihilator with
deadly force right
we can always justify ourselves argue
self-defense but instead of helping
we're destroying if only we had better
knowledge said the chemist the engineer
shook his head with better knowledge
we'd see each side was right in its own
way
and so
it's impossible to really understand to
generate an understanding
of the
condition the mindsets the
socio-history
of these other beings even though
they're much closer to us than a
sentient ocean
finally we have his master's voice
written later than these works right and
it's very interesting because
what is his master's voice
it is a transmission
that at first people were doubtful about
and then they realized no no this is a a
regular transmission from the stars
and it's it's a letter is how they think
about it but it's a letter
without any
of the things that we need in order to
translate it and one of the things that
they do and this is where it connects it
to
the um solaris ocean one of the things
that they do is they say
oh perhaps this is genetic coding
and they
use it to create
several compounds which are
alive
which do things they call them frog eggs
and lord of the flies now here's a
really interesting summary by the main
character the narrator of his master's
voice and he says that
he's talking to a senator he says keep
in mind that we've done what lay within
our power to do and so imposed our
knowledge perhaps simplified or
erroneous notions on the code
mcmahon asked how this was possible if
it was very much like the breaking of a
cipher and he says it is possible
um
that the fret the translation was false
if we were to send telegraphically the
genotype of a man
and the receiver were able to synthesize
on the basis of that only white blood
cells he would end up with amoeba-like
things as well as an enormous amount of
unused information one cannot say that
he who produces corpuscles having before
him the human genotype has read the
message correctly the differences on
that order yes we made use of two to
four percent of the entire code but that
is not all because within that small
percent there could be a full third
that's guesswork we put ourselves into
the translation from our knowledge of
stereochemistry physics and so on if the
genotype of man were read to a similar
similarly low degree one could not even
construct white blood cells at the most
something in the nature of a lifeless
protein suspension i think incidentally
that conducting precisely such
experiments with the human genotype
which has been deciphered to about 70
percent would be extremely instructive
for us but we cannot do this because we
don't have the time or the resources and
then
the senator asks him what was the
difference in development that separated
us from the senders of the message and
he says
i don't know
we don't have enough information there's
no way to actually tell we are looking
at crumbs from the table of this higher
civilization
and we
we just simply don't have enough to work
on we can project anything that we want
onto these
aliens but that's speculation that's not
really
getting ethics and then i'll generate a
you know vast literature about this as
well and so this is really an important
theme
that i think ties things together for
much of lem's works when we're looking
at things that we we could say are
speculative but more realistic science
fiction his attitude is not only
skeptical but pessimistic in this way
about the possibility of ever really
understanding
alien life
when he's doing comedy when he's doing
satire like you know the the various uh
space man uh john ticky stories or or
you know pricks a pilot well then you
know we can understand aliens well
enough they're just as screwed up as as
we are but that's not that's not
remotely realistic that's sort of
playing around with things so this is a
great
way to end talking about this
this really amazing
novel of speculative fiction not just
science fiction but
you know revealing an awful lot of other
stuff to us in the process even though
like so many
platonic dialogues it is operatic
meaning that it doesn't lead us
to the kind of conclusion that we're
looking for we don't understand the
ocean we don't even understand the human
beings that are involved all that well
but we have perhaps
learned something on the way
[Music]
you